hat jemand geklaut seitdem funktioniert
das nicht mehr von kraft wobei mir bot
mir ja der sky macht berufes abgebrochen
weil thema den gehosteten applaus
die intelligente person mein ob die
platte nicht bei dir
wer ist da irgendwas nicht ausreichend
am richtung nervt nur eine folge wären
weil einfach ohne also wenn man alles
soll auch die schule was auch immer dann
ist hier richtig schlecht eigentlich so
gar nicht besser als diamant der mann
aber halt winkler gepasst aber die ihr
alles scheiße ist nicht übertrieben gut
eigentlich schreibt ein skelett
hey alter die 2 ja nein skeleton
da habe ich jetzt englisch so einen cent
das ist probleme das spiel auf englisch
spielt ich spiele aber englisch ich
werde mich immer mal bespielt auf
deutsch auf englisch konnte interessiert
mich verstanden das macht die grünen aus
was hast du für eine rüstung reisen fast
gar nichts ich lasse mich mal mit dem
ist ist er aktiv aktiv
der schweizer holt der ich stand la wann
es hat keinen schaden gemacht
egal wie vielleicht was ihm gleich tot
die für das programm
1 2 3 4 5 6 1 aber fast gar keine
rüstung von daher
wenn ich werde ja auch schön aus
wer hat hier eine rettung geklaut
jetzt jemand zweifelt außerdem
funktioniert das nicht mehr
kontrakte abgebaut
bei mir passt mir wirklich besser ich
würde es ohne spaß ist so sag ich nur
sie erst noch ich weiß aber ich würde
das schloss ist lang und vielleicht der
cloud der war dass dieser sparkurs
ich bin in meinem keller und mein chef
ist der fall eindeutig etwa kommen dir
helfen
nein ich finde noch einen weg heraus
bist du nun geregelt zu treffen
ich probiere es hier einfach irgendwo
durchzugehen nämlich war ich weiß das
ist irgendwie noch durchgeht ist und
hier springen jetzt einfach ruhe
ich habe ich absolut kein ding hingegen
h also ich mir jemals vollkommen crafter
helfen lassen müsste also irgendwie
verkehrt rollenverteilung und schoss
direkt im haus doch nicht wie jetzt im
haus das man guckt so runter man sieht
so die schöne städte über neueste dieses
megaprojekt dorf das ist ganz komisch
dass man darüber nach ich kann nicht
mehr klicken
diamanten vielleicht geht's dann wieder
ja dann steht also touchscreen man ja
einfach auf seinem bildschirm herum
okay geht nicht so lange bis er umfällt
ist wieder abgestürzt dann unterbricht
kurz nein also jetzt geht's wieder
welche wieder mal im keller gut ich kann
mich so hoch bauen ja nein was ich hoffe
es aber ich schaff ohne hilfe hier raus
ist so werden die optimistischen rufe
ich gesagt der unschuld oder so viel
angst dass meine maschine kaputt man die
dinger ja ich hab es aber es ist schwer
also wie gesagt leute ich mal etwas zu
einer danach beschäftige ich mich mit
dem ganzen kreis weil ich denke wenn ich
dann hier fertig bin bin ich ja erstmal
stufen vaart die nächsten folgen da
im urlaub zwei wochen unter mich drei
wochen zu hause dann werde ich mich mit
ihnen zu beschäftigen weil ich jetzt
aufhöre sache haben eine abschlussfahrt
im krankenhaus wegen ereignis auf der
abschlussfahrt oder bei also wegen
blinddarm damen blind ja genau der
vorteil dass beim internetanbieter ich
bin zu blöd loszugehen uns nicht schlimm
weil ja nicht dass man haus richtig
richtig hoch wie bei allen anderen
herrscht aber wenn man darüber reden
kann was man macht dann weiß ich machen
soll
das wird vielleicht sollten wir einfach
da ich habe es geschafft und unkonkret
ab jetzt muss ich nur noch schaffen in
meinen keller zu kommen
die ersten jets nicht wieder runter
außerdem habe ich auch brot negativ
negativ
jetzt müsste eigentlich alles wieder
funktionieren
der tag der sg wallau es funktioniert ja
schauen wir mal von oben an fuhren so
ein spiel habe ich gesagt wo ist mein ja
es funktioniert wieder beste wo ist mein
essen jetzt schreiben schon alle wieder
in die kommentare
dort und gekippte studierte worden weil
er dumm ist akzeptiert dass endlich
schreibt es mir doch einfach jetzt live
per facebook stellt eben rein aber nein
die kann ich auch nicht was ich schade
ganz so liebe nicht überlegen was zu
essen auf jeden fall ich dir einfach
sag' ich habe ein ziel ich es diamanten
alter ich habe er diamanten als essen
ja aber nur weil du diamanten von mir
ich habe jetzt den spektrum gebe ich dir
ein elfter jemand gesagt haben reich
bleiben will muss man nehmen dass du
bist aber ich dachte ich wollte ja neue
helfenden man nicht abzockern wenn man
3he leitbilder bekommen können dass man
die kontrolle wenn ich auf diese folge
mit dass hängenbleibt des zuschauerraums
nicht mehr
50 freiwillige mit dem goya
aber meine schnauze bleibt jetzt hier
du bleibst hier drin in der konfi aber
lautlos dem ich die folge angefangen
haben muss noch drin muss auch hier
bleiben geht ja was okay okay ist okay
dieses mal kaputt und meine ob sie im
platte ich war nicht bei dir
wer ist da irgendwas ist die frist laut
leise spricht ja ich wollte gehen aber
er meinte deutsche bleiben wolltest du
gern ag essen das du trotzdem nicht dass
so wie wir meinen es gefängnis geht
einfach toll spielt boost usa dürften
also ich mein agennix doch
dabei machen tun ja ich bin wirklich weg
dann fühlen wir uns noch ne frage an
dich
was war los jetzt will keine frage
stellen findet sich dann voll witzig ich
warte ja aber nicht mehr lange mitmacht
und ich kümmer nicht nur darum ist mein
haus ist ihm noch hier
für mich hat eine frage an dich kann ich
hier die impfstellen sobald wirklich weg
und gehen auch jetzt nicht weg ich habe
keine frage also bezüglich koffer wenn
ich koche induction deshalb geht kaputt
ist so glaubt er mir nicht mal die
schnauze jetzt ehrlich das war schon
toll wenn ich komm induction für das hat
und da wird dann halt links raus normal
kokain gartner
warum in deutschen gründe angegeben
fragen
antworte ihm gar nicht erst rollen
zurück
also ich hab bei den deutschen fans in
der wirt kopf heraus ja funktioniert
leider nie über genau eine stunde 60
aktionäre der verdacht in ein bisschen
zeit
wundervoll ich glaube machen mobilen
atomreaktor stand des berufes
abgebrochen weil thema den gehosteten
applaus
die intelligente person na gut ich warte
jetzt einfach dass lena anruft weil ich
hab kein bock hier mich zu unterwerfen
deswegen warten wir darauf dass die
jetzt an ruft hey yo yo aufgelegt die
insgeheim qualys voll scheiße
er hätte sie wieder bessert sich langsam
besser wenn es wieder in ordnung
gegangen
besser bei mir ist nicht besser wird
noch einer kommt langsam
ja ja ja jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
eigentlich wollte noch eine frage
stellen
irgendwie glaube ich nicht ich glaube
der wusste keiner weise können immer
zwei leute zu glaubt der muss einfach
keine ahnung
er ist einfach so dumm walter muss
erstmal die ganzen grundstücke sind
direkt an das ist doch auf jeden fall
skate logik würde ich jetzt mal so groß
sei wichtig dass kate ja gut das ist
brocken samstag weiß ich da ist einfach
so obsidian in der luft sowie die kinder
soll es dann irgendwie vergiftet ich
glaube das land rollen das gab das als
kate gemacht bei den kunden finden die
gar nix für obsidian um den formal ja
ich glaube das was kate sieht jedoch
ähnlich oder ich glaube das wird macht
es geht immer skate sieht sperma ähnlich
experten gesagt danke existiert also
kann ich noch oder bin ich los es gibt
ganz viele vulkan deswegen weiß nicht ob
der speziell von dir genannte auch er
ist fast komplett weg und obendrauf zu
nietzsches alter wenn es draufsteht
wer bekommt jetzt an mir vorbeigeflogen
mit deiner scheiße quanto mose habe ich
gar nicht nötig mit zoe ich gar kein
bock drauf das ist nur noch mit ihrem
blog
die würde ich so dass er mit seinem
zauberstab hier wieder fliegt dann
einfach weg zu ändern